[Música]
crujiente esponjosa deliciosa e icónica
la baguette es un símbolo del francés y
ahora es miembro del prestigioso club
del patrimonio mundial el estatus de
patrimonio cultural y material se
confiere las prácticas que tienen un
valor histórico cultural y universal
para la humanidad y ayuda a protegerlas
para las generaciones futuras una
solicitud que ha sido bien acogida por
el público francés
Es algo bueno Siempre es una ventaja y
reconocerá el Duro trabajo de los
panaderos
la historia de amor de Francia con la
baguette despegó de verdad a principios
del siglo XX con la modernización de los
métodos de producción con la
industrialización del proceso el pan se
abarató y se hizo más fácil de elaborar
destronando otra tradición francesa La
hogaza de campo el pan se convirtió en
un símbolo político con políticos de
diferentes partes del espectro
blandiéndolo con orgullo hoy en día
Francia cuenta con más de 30.000
panaderías en todo el país y se calcula
que cada segundo se compran 320
baguettes esto supone un consumo total
de al menos 6000 millones de baguettes
al año en 2021 el presidente de Francia
Emmanuel maccon lanzó la candidatura
para que la baguette recibiera el
estatus de patrimonio de la humanidad
para la alegría de este panadero en
particular vamos a participar en el
resplandor de Francia y en la
gastronomía francesa ya que seguirá
formando parte de esta gastronomía
francesa en arbolado con orgullo bajo en
los brazos de los franceses este pan
emblemático Es realmente un delicioso
símbolo de la cultura francesa